space
the final frontier
these are the voyages
if there's anything i remember about
2013 it was rayman legends and how
tragically underrated that game was
also
there was the vgx awards you remember
welcome to the future of award shows
name one game that you're gonna play
other than all of them and you like them
all no they all a lot of games look
great tonight that's what we that's
what's great about the show is we get
all the others
that
and it was here that no man's sky got
everyone's attention it was a space game
where
uh
i guess you could do everything can you
land on a comet yeah at the moment you
can land on asteroids do the animals eat
each other
yeah they do will you be able to play
with your friends
yeah can you grief other players
a little bit you can also like a lot of
players do
and just not gather resources this isn't
an ambient universe this isn't something
you just wander around and look at trees
honestly as hyped up as the game was
i didn't get it i never really
understood what exactly the actual game
was it was like that dead island
cinematic trailer that hyped up everyone
without actually showing anything
and in 2016 the game was released
but
many of the promise features were
missing and beyond that the game was
incredibly buggy
and oh man
[Music]
but five years later no man's sky is a
different game with an impressive number
of regular updates in fact by many
accounts the game is good now not only
that but it's one of video games
greatest redemption arcs i admittedly
haven't played the game until now but
after seeing heaps of praise for all the
updates it was time to finally pick it
up and discover just who is no man
how does he own the sky
i wanted to see how the game is now and
if someone like myself who wasn't
initially interested in the game would
enjoy it with all of the new updates to
be clear this video isn't meant to be a
review but rather my personal
experiences which may or may not connect
with you so i figured what better way to
do that than install no man's sky in my
ps5 and download the ps5 patch to get
the best experience possible which was
when my ps5 promptly decided to brick
no really i'm waiting for the box right
now so i can ship it back
so i installed the game and its patches
onto my ps4 and promptly hopped into no
man's sky
as i have no friends i decided to check
out the single player mode which
presented me with five options while i
usually like to play a game on normal
first
permadeath let's go
this might not be the smartest idea for
a game i've never played
but it was bold and centered
[Music]
wait i'm already being poisoned uh wait
hold on what element do i need to gather
how
maybe i just got unlucky with the
starting area let's just load up another
permadeath run in
oh [ __ ]
well you know what they say
third time's a charm
okay fine i'll play it on normal before
you judge too harshly you have to
remember i've never played this game
before so i didn't know anything about
the controls mechanics or where to find
the materials i desperately needed so
normal did make sense and finally i
landed on a planet where i immediately
started overheating but had time to
figure out how to solve the issue and
that was when i quickly discovered
something many people had already
mentioned about the game
the fact that everything you own and use
is constantly breaking so i found myself
running around trying to collect carbon
oxygen sodium and other resources to
regularly fix myself up all while
occasionally finding a cave to hide in
from minutes in real time long
firestorms
the first mission i had was to find my
crash starship and rebuild it which i
was genuinely excited to do of all the
planets i'd started on i found this one
to be one of the most bland and ugly so
i was pretty excited to get off of this
god forsaken rock and onto the next
procedurally generated nightmare planet
and after blasting off to my next
mission objective it
it took me right back to another part on
the exact same planet
god damn it my next mission was to
gather another batch of resources
and build a wooden base and shelter i
could use for the extreme heat and uh
firestorms of the planet
i've never felt safer in a wooden hut it
is worth noting that constructing my
wooden base was actually one of the many
features not present in the base game i
guess you had to just hide in caves for
a while or suffer in hellish storms and
cry
although bases were one of the first
updates of the game and added just a
couple months after release with the
foundation update apparently the no
man's sky next update of 2018 is what
let players build bases anywhere as
opposed to specific spots so i could
have also been benefiting from that they
feel pretty integral to the game as they
give you a safe space to construct on
any planet so it's hard to imagine the
game without them
so after surviving a firestorm and
roaming around for even more resources
it was time for me to finally head back
into space this led to my first space
station which actually looks pretty cool
from the outside
i don't understand what any of the
aliens inside are saying but you can ask
them for translations of
uh
one word at a time
and only one word per alien
per each alien race you can also find
knowledge stones on planets that do this
where i learned the geck word
for geck
but back to outer space where the real
fun is to be wait
why can't i boost anymore
oh oh i need more resources
of course
so you don't even get a respite from
resource depletion and management in
space you're constantly running out of
boost fuel which you'll need to shoot
down asteroids to collect and lest i
forget there is space combat but don't
expect any star fox level maneuvering
here
anyways eventually i got the ability for
my spaceship to achieve hyperdrive
meaning i could quickly head to another
star system and new planets away from my
fire hell hole
hyperdrive fuel status empty
after gathering resources for antimatter
i then had to gather even more resources
for an anti-matter housing and you may
be asking yourself but dave why don't
you just gather a ton of each resource
at once that way you'll have everything
you need when you're ready to craft
something new
that's what i thought
stop stealing my thoughts
well you see you have limited space in
your exosuit starship for resources and
crafting something also takes up a slot
in said storage spots there's also
advanced resources you have to put into
a furnace to craft which also takes
extra slots in other words you'll
constantly need to manage what's in your
exosuit and drop resources you don't
currently need
but eventually i blasted off and found a
whole new set of planets and this is
when the game finally started to pick up
i discovered more of the main plot where
i had to try and track down a character
named artemis this ended up being what i
spent a lot of my time doing and
apparently this narrative drive was
actually added in an updated year after
the game's release in 2017 as part of
the atlas rises update it wasn't the
most
interesting storyline and as per no
man's sky's mo every single tiny update
to the story took another round of
gathering resources crafting things
gathering more resources and traveling
back and forth between planets but at
least it gave me some kind of drive
honestly it's kind of unbelievable this
wasn't in the game at launch as it felt
absolutely integral for keeping me at
least somewhat interested in the game
while also teaching me some of the
game's mechanics after following this
storyline to a third cluster of planets
i finally discovered a really cool
multiplayer nexus that i could summon
called the space anomaly
which is another feature that was added
in the updates while to my understanding
the nexus did exist the fact that i
actually found players who i could
interact with uh very minorly and try to
join a group with was something that was
part of the beyond update of august 2019
and it was here in the space anomaly i
received a new mission outside of the
main story to find a black hole
oh hell yeah now this is what i'm
talking about sure it's three to four
star systems away from where i'm
currently at meaning i'll have to gather
a crap ton of resources craft things run
out of resources i need and craft more
things but finding a black hole sounds
amazing
and on my way i discovered some cool
sights this cool creature that
uh oh
goodbye
and a couple of genuinely cool looking
planets with saturn-like rings around
them that looked especially cool at
night with the rain glowing in the night
sky
and finally
i did it i found the black hole
something i was told to go through and
would be super exciting now that that is
a cool looking feature i've always
wondered what the inside of a black hole
would look like here we go
[Music]
uh wait hold on a second this just looks
like any other solar system in the game
and how did i get on this couch
uh oh
i just warped far away
so far away that i'm in a solar system
that is completely disconnected from
every other narrative storyline i'm
following meaning i'm just going to have
to warp right back to where i was before
trying to find the black hole
worth it you know i traveled this far
might as well make a base on this planet
that looks kind of like earth if earth
experienced extreme storms with
lightning everywhere firestorms was
quite possibly the most brutal planet of
any i'd found so far and was 580 degrees
fahrenheit
i'll just go ahead and name my new base
back in the solar system with the
artemis quest i found myself doing
another addition to the game's 2017
update procedurally generated missions
all of which were basically fetch quests
and some of which even required me to
warp to other solar systems
meaning i had to gather resources craft
materials for a warp cell and then
gather more resources and then craft
more resources and gather more graphs
and resources
[Music]
eventually i decided to try warping to
another player's base they dubbed
sentinel colossus just because it looked
cool stared in awe at their masterpiece
and then realized it was just like the
rest of the game
completely hollow it looked cool but
ultimately it couldn't actually do
anything
and that was when i returned to the main
game and realized something no matter
what happened i was stuck in this
perpetual loop of exploring procedurally
generated worlds for resources that i
was constantly running out of only to
blast off to new bland procedurally
generated world for more resources i was
constantly running out of that's it
that was the game and the biggest
criticism no man's sky faced at launch
which is still very much the meat of the
game it doesn't matter how many updates
you slap on it multiplayer or not more
variation of plant fauna and creatures
or not harder easier versions of the
exact same thing or not bigger base
building or not the game was quantity
over quality procedurally generated
monotony no matter how pretty some of
the planets might be ultimately there
was nothing worth exploring as i knew it
was just another bland procedurally
generated world with the same basic crap
on it at this point i need to mention a
few things for one there is now a
version of the game you can choose
called creative mode which takes out the
constant survival elements
but that's kind of most of what the
gameplay is so i personally feel weird
choosing that mode as just about every
upgrade you find is one to make this
process slightly less tedious it takes
out what little gameplay there is in
this game and if it's a sandbox game
you're looking for frankly there's games
that do it better also one more thing i
need to say this video isn't a review if
you like or love no man's sky that's
great maybe this type of resource
management game is your jam and i know
that some people find the game relaxing
it's completely subjective and i'm not
trying to detract from your experience
if it's a game that connected with you
and i want to be honest with my personal
experience i know that many people
really enjoy no man's sky now and all
the new updates have turned it into the
game they were hoping for it's a
difficult thing because i'm not trying
to tell you how you should feel and i
know many people are going to tear me
apart because of my experience
for my part despite all the updates all
i could find was an endless loop of
tedious tasks in front of me i do think
the updates helped to an extent
especially base building in the
narrative but it's still culminated in
the same gameplay loop and maybe
resource management survival games just
aren't for me i don't know the thing is
i tend to enjoy most games i play video
games are my favorite form of
entertainment and i like practically
every genre of game be it rpg platformer
adventure game action game fps farming
simulator racing games sports game rts
metroidvania survival horror room escape
strategy name it and i probably like it
i also enjoy sci-fi i'm a huge star trek
the next generation fan and find outer
space fascinating
but this is one of the very few games i
played that i just did not understand
the appeal whatsoever there's games like
harvest moon stardew valley or rune
factory while you're doing chores in
these games you still have a steady goal
of building up your farm or romancing a
character and the chores manage to feel
far less tedious as their simple tasks
which is part of the charm of those
games
while you can now build bases in no
man's sky it's ultimately about
exploration but the chores hinder that
goal and what's there to explore isn't
really all that interesting every
environment i explored felt bland
uninspired and just as procedurally
generated as they were
i love exploring both in games and in
real life but if you give me a game like
breath of the wild there's always
something exciting to find around each
corner or at the very least i can find
pride in climbing up to the top of a
cool looking mountain or there's dark
souls where every area feels handcrafted
and oozes with lore and meaning that
doesn't exist in no man's sky there's
nothing exciting to find and constantly
refilling your dwindling resources isn't
a rewarding feeling as you explore a
little bit further
i mean i did fall in this cave this one
time and i guess that was a little
exciting because i didn't realize it was
there as i was so focused on trying to
run to the next resource i had to grab
and the first time i saw water was
pretty exciting until i realized it was
just visual and while i could swim it
didn't really change the gameplay my
reward for getting further in the game
was that i had to then construct more
complicated things that took more basic
resources and just another loop of
everything i'd done before
and look maybe if i put 100 hours in i'd
find an enjoyable end game but i have
absolutely no drive to get there or to
do that and even if i did it would just
be crafting items i could use to better
explore planets that have nothing
interesting on them to find and yes i'm
sure the game would have looked better
on pc or if my ps5 hadn't betrayed me
and pooped out on me but graphics can't
fix bland gameplay
my criticisms aside i do want to commend
hello games i can completely see the
difficult position they were in when the
game first released they were a small
indie developer who were picked up by a
major publisher in sony and ended up
having this insane expectation and
deadline put on their shoulders they
didn't have to release a giant number of
free updates that turned their game into
their initial vision
and yet over the course of 5 years they
have and while it isn't for me i do
think it's great what they did and there
are people out there who really love the
game now while i do think they over
promised by pitching the game on
features they hoped to include but
likely hadn't implemented yet in the end
hello games took the high road not a
single update as of today has included
some extra form of payment and i think
they were really passionate about their
vision
even if i didn't like it luckily after
no man's sky everyone learned their
lesson no one over hyped a game before
release or got overly excited for a game
before anyone had ever actually played
it ever
again
[Music]
had someone betray me just like that
once
[Music]
so
you